yo what's up everybody this is
international master Daniel drench this
is chest comms YouTube channel and today
we're back with another exciting video
here on our chess openings playlist
things that you need to know for your
tournament chess career and here today
we've got the Grunfeld defense as you
can see from the title which starts at 4
d4 Knight f6 c4 g 6 9 - c3 and the move
d5 those of you who follow our playlists
here closely and subscribe to our
channel know that I've already covered
the Kings Indian defense which goes
after Bishop to g7 efore and eventually
d6 and this would be a mainline Kings
Indian but as said today we are not
talking about the Kings India we were
talking about the slightly more
aggressive brother opening you might
call it as it starts out with the same
first two moves but then black quickly
takes a more aggressive approach
challenging White's Center and in doing
so making it taking an inherent risk in
terms of his positional ideas and before
I talk about that inherent risk I want
to back up and explain one basic
fundamental idea behind the Queen's pawn
opening right in the King's pawn for
example if we were talking about a
regular Queens gambit is that white
chooses to challenge the center with
pawns more directly why is this
important for the Grunfeld because the
idea is that white wants to put pressure
against this pawn hoping for black to
take it why and many cases if black
takes it if he doesn't get immediate
pressure against the D pawn or if he
doesn't know opening theory white may
eventually just pick up this pawn right
back and in turn have a great Center
because what he did by giving up the C
pawn was forced black to give up a
center pawn for a winged pawn take a
good look at this type of position here
and note that this type of pawn
structure would be considered a
positional advantage for white and one
of the main ideas behind playing a
Queen's pawn game to begin with so when
we back up and take a look at the
Grunfeld
we notice that the idea of playing d5
seems a little bit counterintuitive for
black after white captures on d5 and
plays e4 hasn't white just achieved
exactly what he wants in the Queen's
pawn game to begin with where there
would be a grünfeld or a Queen's Gambit
or any kind of opening that is a great
pawn center a great pawn formation that
is giving white a ton of space
well what black gets in return for that
is compensation to talk about the
conversation we flipped the board here
and show that after the move Knight
takes c3 B takes c3 black has yes given
white this great center however in
capturing on c3 and forcing this pawn to
come here
he's created a target along this long
diagonal the a1h a diagonal after the
move Bishop to g7 black intends to
develop his pieces with specific purpose
to play c5 to play Knight to c6 to
develop this Queen to either be six or a
five or in some cases c7 with all of
those moves putting pressure against
White's dark squares and eventually he
may even use the d8 square for a rook so
black as we said has given white a
positional advantage in order to have
something to attack right he's given his
opponent a bone so that he can go and
try and get it now if white doesn't
understand how to develop let's say he
plays moves like Knight f3 and Bishop e2
which are both totally ok moves but if
black is able to increase his pressure
and white doesn't understand what to do
here like an awkward moves such as
Bishop f4 for example here black has
already played several moves that are
putting direct pressure against White's
Center and now moves like Bishop c4
might eliminate this Knight which can
only help black and his goal to win d4
as the knight is a critical defender
moves like Queen b6 and Queen a5 were
possible and all of them together should
be considered after move Bishop g4 black
might consider this perhaps bring the
other two rooks to the center and put
pressure against White's grey pawn so
yes White has a center but the center at
this point is a target so if you're
white and you're playing against the
grünfeld
how might you choose to develop in order
to be best prepared for black's plans of
c5 and nine to c6 and and basically
pressure along this long diagonal noted
again should be that usually moves like
capturing the pawn don't believe the
pressure as they almost always unleash
instant tactics for this hidden dragon
over there crouching bishop on g7 hidden
dragon that's right I just did two
chou-heung fan reference here in the
crouching tiger-hidden dragon reference
of the opening that's hysterical let's
be honest anyway so how should white
development order be ready for these
types of breaks well typically the best
move has been considered to be this move
Bishop to c4 why because after c5 you
can now use the square
eetu without blocking your own bishop on
f1 the 92 is best placed for defending
not only d4 but also this potentially
weak c3 pawn after moves like castles
castles nine to c6 but white can
continue with moves like Bishop e3 and
we see all of ice pieces coordinating to
the best effort to the best of their
abilities to defend this these critical
dar squares and if he's able to achieve
such a defense and continue with let's
say moves like rook c1 and bring more
pieces to the center then this
positional advantage the black gave him
back in the beginning of the game being
these two pawns here will indeed come to
something so as I'm saying if black
played let's say purely passive moves
with no plan at all you know randomly
awkward moves white will bring all the
pieces to the center and eventually
really be happy with his space advantage
that restricts his opponent's pieces so
this main line usually with white place
this way is met by a dynamic plan for
black which involves taking on d4
pinning the night on e - and eventually
playing for dynamic play that goes like
this where white actually can sacrifice
the exchange along this diagonal in
order for a very strong mating attack
but black has the long-term advantage of
material and a potential two-on-one
majority now what I just did right there
is give you a little insight information
to the deeper theory of the line but in
these types of videos here we don't have
time to discuss everything on a very
deep theoretical level so what you got
in here is a basic summary of the
philosophy behind the grünfeld defense I
am giving white an advantage in the
center in order to have a target for the
rest of the game as I prepared my pieces
to be ready to challenge these squares
and from White's perspective White's
should know to develop the bishop and
bring the Knight to e2 where it is best
placed to defend these center pawns
develop his pieces accordingly
afterwards and hopefully hold on to the
center to have a better a better
position if you're white so that's the
Grunfeld in under 7 minutes and I hope
you enjoyed it hope you enjoyed this
video and I'll see you around on chess
calm